hunting down vampires is hard work but
someone's got to do it here's everything
you need to know about evil West
well West is an action-filled gory
fast-paced third person shooter with a
narrative driven linear campaign so it
goes without saying you'll be doing a
lot of shooting along with a healthy mix
of melee as well at Jesse's disposal are
the gauntlet a powerful melee weapon
with electrified upgraded versions that
can stun enemies or turn them into Ash
and the scorcher a flamethrower that
uses the gauntlet's energy to refuel its
tank over time there are of course also
more traditional shooter weapons such as
the institute's signature shotgun for
close range combat the revolver for
close to mid-range and the rifle for
precision and long range Bullseye each
weapon in the game has its own skill
tree so you can customize your playstyle
and learn new ways to take out the
vampires
in evil West you play as Jessie rentier
one of the last agents in a top secret
Monster hunting Institute led by your
father William this institute has been
eliminating vampiric monsters since the
early 18th century and you're one of the
most proficient unpredictable and
stubborn Hunters your trusty partner is
a senior agent by the name of Edgar
gravenor a man with his eyes on
retirement after years of helping your
father Safeguard Pioneers from threats
to the frontier another key member of
The Institute is Amelia Blackwell an
expert medic and researcher on all
things sangwa suj aka the newest blood
sucking threat
long hidden in the shadows the sangu suj
aren't your typical vampires these
monsters consist of boo hags a deadly
creature with low intelligence often
traveling in packs naggles fast
ambushers with a unique ability to avoid
small caliber gunfire with their Shadow
step bleachers massive creature with
spiky Shields that can regenerate their
defense when the shields are destroyed
and highborns the strongest of the bunch
that use their powerful Wings to deliver
devastating aerial attacks and can cause
swarms to fast to heal them and destroy
you you'll be taking all these creatures
across all the American frontier deep
Canyons abandoned towns gold mines and
old Sawmills will act as the backdrop to
your fight against evil
vampiric monsters can be pretty scary
but not to worry you don't have to take
on the threat alone evil West features
an online co-op for an entire campaign
but only the host progresses the story
both you and a friend will play as Jesse
and encounter challenges with slightly
different enemy compositions than when
playing alone
[Music]
evil West is developed by flying wild
hog a Polish Studio behind the Shadow
Warrior series this game is being
published by Focus entertainment and was
first officially announced at the 2020
game awards it was originally scheduled
for release on September 20th 2022 but
was later delayed to November during PAX
East 2022 a producer for the game told
Escapist magazine that evil West is
inspired by the combo system of the
Devil May Cry series and the third
person camera angle combat and finishers
of God of War 2018. so if you like
either of those games evil West might be
right up your alley evil West is
releasing on PS4 PS5 Xbox One Sirius XMS
and PC on November 22nd 2022 for more on
evil West including our review of the
game make sure to subscribe to GameSpot
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]